Jake will [ __ ] up most boxers
he will [ __ ] up most MMA guys I mean I
think we've already proven that in a
boxing
I think he'd be the first person to say
like I'm not beating any of these guys
in MMA this is what their expertise is
but he's taking it seriously and then I
imagine Tate who's probably in his 30s
right 35 36 yeah yeah he probably hasn't
fought in a few years like that that is
like a whole transition in life to go do
something to prove what you were already
a world champion kickboxer what do you
prove by beating beating Jake maybe you
get a Payday maybe it's I think there's
a number amount okay let's say you get
five million let's say you get 10
million is it worth it I don't know what
the guy's worth but if you got a hundred
million or whatever maybe he's saying he
got in the bank like is it worth it for
five is it worth it to train for six
months your rotator cuffs [ __ ] up your
eye already has issues like is that
worth it for five or could you take
those six months and apply yourself to
another business